he's Reggie Miller the hall-of-famer
Turner Sports NBA analyst and he'll be
on the call coming up Thursday 92 10:30
Eastern but Nuggets and the Warriors
along with Kevin Harlan well I believe
one the sportscaster of the Year award
again I think and now Allie LaForce so
reg will be on the call of that game on
Thursday night
good morning reg did you watch the
national title game I did and yes does
believe back-to-back years for my
colleague and one of my good friends
Kevin Harlan to win back-to-back
forecaster of the year so it's awesome
for him and his family yeah good stuff
would you take away from the national
title what number one Joe burrow is good
Justin Reggie Miller says Joe Burrell is
good no no I mean but because here what
I'm reading is who had the the better
season Cam Newton I believe in was that
2014 or 15 when his Auburn Tigers went
undefeated and he won the Heisman or
jobber oh this particular year and cam
was fantastic and that Auburn team
fantastic but it just seemed that Joe
burrow and this LSU Tigers what was
interesting was I always love to hear
what your teammates have to say for you
now obviously they're going to say nice
things but to hear the cornerbacks to
hear the the linebackers to hear
obviously their receivers
how much admiration and respect and how
hard they say this young man works
this dude is good this dude is good but
there's something about that confidence
I don't know if it's arrogance or cocky
but he certainly knows that he's good
you could get that sense that it's
almost controlled swag on his part
there's nothing wrong with that no and
especially if you directed the right way
as long as you work hard and you prepare
and at times beat over I don't care how
cocky you are I don't care how you sure
are you getting the job done that's the
bottom line
are you getting the job done but when
you started to do it when you see guys
who were confident on a basketball floor
at what point did you go this is I can
show this person I can be this guy
because you have to live up to that then
every single night after that you do and
again I know how much blood sweat tears
I put into my practice regime so I
wasn't worried about what people thought
of me on the court because I was only
doing my job my job was to win ball
games score points and antagonize you
all right not everyone can wear the
white hat and I think Joe burrow
understands that there are some guys I
got to wear the black hat Theodore yeah
yeah and I think and is confident and at
times borderline cocky Joe burrow is I
will take that I want confident young
men but what did you decide that you
could wear the black hat and that you
had the opposition the fans or did the
media give it to you I don't know if you
consciously said hey I'm okay with being
the bad guy I think I was always okay I
think you know growing up in the shadow
of my sister it kind of evolved in
itself you know always being you know
Cheryl Miller's little brother and you
know in high school going on opposing
roads and here in the crowd so you kind
of I kind of morphed into that a little
bit and they kind of stuck with me at
UCLA having somewhat of a bad reputation
and then you know you know growing up
with Michael Cooper and magic as the
guys that said no now dude do it this
way and I was like oh really I can do it
this way and yeah and I was like okay
well here it is
yeah but then you and then you know
you're not going to be didn't you want
to be liked when you're playing in the
age you know people you know say well
you're playing with Michael joy in the
era of Michael Jordan and Joe Dumars
still guys were beloved well-loved
well-liked that just wasn't me I didn't
care basically I didn't care really I
think here if you like it or not
I cared about did the Indiana faithful
love me which I hope they did and
respected the way I played that's all
that matter did my teammates respect
what I did each and every night that's
all that's all I cared about but it
feels like there are very few players
nowadays like draymond Green doesn't
care if you like him or not but it feels
like most players want to be liked well
part of this is the AAU because you're
switching teams every week to form super
teams so everyone is buddy-buddy and you
know let's go to dinner and let's talk
about this it you know we didn't have a
easy that AAU generation wasn't part of
you know my upbringing and social media
too and social media and you you can
kind of you know this very well Theodore
how did we know about players back east
or in the south it was that five-on-five
Street and Smith magazine right yeah you
know that's you you would get that
magazine and you would look at the
rankings and you'd be like wait a minute
are you kidding me who is this who is
Reggie Williams who is Reggie Lewis who
is Joshi I mean that's what I used to do
like and that's the disdain I used to
kind of grow up with like who's ranking
these guys who who gets invited to these
you know Garr Garfunkel camps and Villa
del gets invited to those things so
that's where the chip kind of evolved
for me like why are they thinking those
guys are better than me talking to
Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Thursday
night he's got Nuggets and the Warriors
can you explain this Kevin Durant
Kendrick Perkins beef I can't other than
the fact I think both sides are somewhat
right I think basketball purists will
probably look at KD and be like dude you
had you had that same team down 3-1 and
a chance to go on to the finals and lost
and then you joined them next year
I think basketball purist think that but
on the flip side we in the media I don't
because I'm part of the thing that never
wanted championship I don't know if you
are Theodore but everyone talks about
Championships Championships
Championships the guy is never great
until they win a championship yeah so
what is Katy suppose
to do all right is he going to stay in
OKC and battle the Warriors all the time
and and maybe won a championship or join
them and win back-to-back the Finals MVP
back-to-back it had a chance to win
three in a row
and now he's in the discussion and being
part of that Mount Rushmore is it
Championships or do you want guys to be
loyal right because if he's loyal and
doesn't win a championship
the media says well you didn't win a
championship your MVP of the league but
you couldn't win a championship so you
can't have it both ways people well we
did that to LeBron the media drove him
out of Cleveland because it kept saying
yeah you call yourself the King and the
chosen one yeah so that goes to Miami
and then you know he gets beat up
because all you had to go join Dwyane
Wade and Chris Bosh and and then once he
won a couple of titles then he was able
to go back try to win right learn how to
win from Dwyane Wade right he understood
how to win and came back and corrected
the situation correct by winning a
championship in Cleveland which seems
like two or three to me when you win in
a small market like that yeah Kevin have
you seen Kevin Garnett's acting skills
in uncut gems with Adam Sandler I liked
I mean obviously he was playing Kevin
Garnett I love the movie I thought over
the holiday I you know I texted him and
told him I was going to contribute to
the fund and I liked it
he was pretty boys at a big KC fan it's
good yeah I mean your voice and ler
because you're in Weymouth
come on you weren't in this movie
because you're in every Sandler movie I
[Music]
I know why you weren't in it because it
really wasn't a comedy there's more of
us yes yes comedy yeah okay absolutely
and and plus I can't work with kg you
know it's just that we were just
different actors I'm more able to work
with Chris Webber than I am with KJ
joking just joking oh by the way I bet
kg was great being cagey obviously
because if you know K gene you know his
mannerism
I mean you appreciate that so him being
cagey on full effect for everyone to see
was great
did you see Zion nearly fall asleep on
the bench I did and it was funny is they
did a side by side because I don't know
if you've seen the Charles Barkley
fallen asleep in the studio side-by-side
and it was absolutely hilarious if I'm
dying I'm almost calling c2 I'm tired I
want to play and for what we're hearing
what this Thursday he's 19 how can you
be tired you're not even playing I want
to play so maybe this Thursday we see
the unveiling of Mount Zion
maybe I'm tired I want to play do you
know something about Zion Zion coming
back
I like their Sadie is getting close
maybe maybe this Thursday versus Utah
maybe don't think so I don't know I
it sounds like you may know something
and you're just I know I know Justin
okay all right by the way James Harden
vs. John Moran tonight which might be a
little spicy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Reggie you know that hardens gonna get
75 in a game this year
hey I don't know about this year but if
they don't change the world at some
point in his career he's gonna he's
gonna get the 70 plus one
he's not gonna get two he might not get
to 81 he might not get to Kobe territory
but if you take we're gonna get to 70
plus I agree Yeah right he's gonna get
to 70 plus I don't know about this
season but in the next couple years
James Harden will get 70 plus points in
a game you see a hall-of-famer right now
yeah yes one time in VP
he's been runner-up in VP what three
times two times I think two seven-time
all-star seven-time our scoring leader
yes he's a first-ballot hall-of-famer
Chris Paul first ballot hall-of-famer
Russell Westbrook first-ballot
hall-of-famer with the Rockets Lima
better with Chris Paul uh I think OKC is
better with a they've been they've been
one of the surprising teams but that's
not what I asked reg I'm gonna reserve
judgment until I see how they perform
come playoff time because I think Brody
will elevate his game come in be a
playoff time but I'm reserving judgment
because we all know we've seen this
movie before
fabulous regular season right off the
number charts for James Harden but come
playoff time
second round possibly third round exit
so I'll reserve judgment LA Times had an
article Lakers GM Rob polenka prepared
to trade anyone on the roster except
Anthony Davis and LeBron James if it
means filling a gap the Lakers need in
order to win a championship
according to a purse familiar with his
thinking so what is the gap what did the
Lakers need
if I'm the Lakers I would probably
because you're you're pretty solid at
that center position with McGee and
Howard the question will be maybe maybe
point guard if you want to give the
Brawn a little bit of rest where he's
leading the league in assists look do
they have what 37 wins 35 and 7 they
seem to be doing ok unless they I baked
you Rob
like what gap do you want the 35 and 7
unless they're looking at a matchup come
postseason like everybody would always
gear up because they knew they're facing
the Patriots so how do we gear up our
team to face the patriot it and unless
the later here's the thing I think
everyone's gearing up to defend ad and
LeBron why are we why are we
counteracting why are we counter jabbing
we're the Lakers were 35 and 7 what gap
do we need to fill unless you just want
to you know get rid of Kuzma and get
some pieces back or some draft fix the
Lakers are stacked you people may not
like their roster but I like the
experience they have Dudley Rondo McGee
has won a championship up in Golden
State Howard has something to prove so I
want players to have that want to you
know go out and you know prove people
wrong the Lakers are stacked I wouldn't
do something drastically to alter this
this lineup being 35 and 7 and having
the best record out west I saw this
story and maybe you could find out more
when you do the the Warriors game
against the Nuggets Thursday night would
you swap if your Philadelphia would you
swap Ben Simmons for D'Angelo Russell no
we have to say that loud well I think
Simmons has a chance to be again not on
par with the Greek freak
Yanis on to decouple but he has that
skill set where he can control the game
in terms of points rebounds and assists
he has to work on her shooting obviously
dramatically but
between him and embiid you've got to
general generational players on that
Sixers team so absolutely not what I
trade D'Angelo for for Ben Simmons oh
that would be great for the Warriors I'm
sure yes cover from the Warriors camp
DeAngelo Russell is a pretty good Pro I
mean he's not one of those he can
dominate a game like Ben can in a
variety of ways except for shooting but
I wish I could have seen him with clay
and with Steph no I think Steph may be
coming back in March maybe maybe not but
I would love to have seen him with those
two and draymond Green just to kind of
see you know how he performs but him
being out there is kind of like him
being in in Brooklyn last year you know
it's him and you know a lot of isolation
high screen and rolls and you know go
one-on-one but you if you're Kevin
Durant would you even hint at coming
back this year hadn't he learned from
what happened at Golden State like don't
put any pressure there's no upside on
this no there's not I wouldn't I
wouldn't we finished in the seventh or a
seed to face
Yanis you finished eighth absolutely not
seven you're probably getting either
Boston or Miami still all right but why
would Steph Curry come back there's a
broken hand versus okay in Achilles
that's a fair that's their answer yes
and can I just say one thing before I go
yes because you know I we you and I both
love baseball and you know I'm the
biggest coup fan okay California Angels
right yes
Los Angeles Angels of Anaheim I know
you're a fan of the band The Who and I
was gonna go oh okay okay you know that
okay but I will say this the Dodgers
says they cannot comment from Major
League Baseball they got screwed in 2017
after knowing what we know now and I
think to a certain extent so the Yankees
is that's unbelievable seriously and I
know not all teams and all teams steal
signs but they just got caught right
yeah but I can't give it to the Dodgers
I would vacate the title if I was going
to do anything I'm not telling you give
it to the Dodgers there's the Yankees
got screwed before the Dodgers did right
I know I would vacate the title ok you
can't give it to the Dodgers because
they lost it on the field but 2017
should be open and the reason why it's
open is because the Astros got caught
cheating yeah I got caught cheating I
mean if baseball came down I thought
that they could have come down even
harder but they should know if the
maximum was 5 million that should have
been 10 million and I know you can't
penalize players core is gonna get it
but look I could have gone to Harvard if
I would have known all the tests and the
question on the SAT Reggie you could
have gone to Harvard to play basketball
no if I would have known all the answers
to my SAT questions I could have done
that come on Astros how many would you
have average hit Harvard back in the 80s
yeah oh my goodness 3540 okay McLovin
McLovin is offended by why why are you
bothered by McLovin would have been the
second best player on your team Reggie
hey have fun please tell Kevin Harlan
congratulations again for taking the
sportscaster of the year I mean for
winning the sportscaster great a great
honor by by him and well dessert see you
know you're the best I love my dad I'll
talk to you guys next week
thank you red
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]